le troisième finale qui vous concerne et
peut-être une troisième victoire comment
ça se présente très bien
le moral est au beau fixe raymond
domenech raymond domenech qui lui a
d'autres soucis il prépare son bac et je
crois que les deux comptant la finale
elle mais enfin qui prend le dessus
la finale sa finale que vous appréciez
vous êtes ingénieur vous avez 19 ans on
a l'impression que vous donnerez
n'importe quel adversaire ce serait la
finale de la coupe du monde vous seriez
toujours aussi calme a toujours pareil
normalement mon espoir pour demain
n'est ce pas s'étant approché voilà yves
chauveau il chauveau lui qui s'est
permis de manquer le départ m'enfin ça
il ya quand même quelques petits ennuis
qu'est ce qui s'est passé rien ne me
prendra huit heures et puis si je vais
me prendre sont pas menées alors du coup
je suis resté en rade
la ccsn mais non pour plus tard
d'ailleurs beaucoup plus tard pour
demain donc pas l'inquiétude et puis je
pense que quand on a une fille dans la
semaine comme serge chiesa 1 ou la coupe
se serait enlevé aux cadeaux baget cdu a
mené ses défauts de les irakiens rendu
public bien qu'elle l'avait rapport
promesses et fera plaisir à tout le
monde et en toute façon en lisant les
palmarès et sera que son père l'a gagné
oui oui certainement
certes ya une semaine mouvementée une
petite fille une finale de coupe ça
représente beaucoup pour un homme
enfin je crois que je pensais qu'à
finale de coupe faim il filme quoi on y
pense non françois plus on sera alors
lui offert la coupe je pense serge cette
première année de cette deuxième année
de professionnalisme marque pour vous je
le pense le joueur à maturité celui
qu'on attendait depuis longtemps
maintenant ces choses réalisées vous
êtes moins tourmenté peut-être
je suis décontracté sûrement et ans mais
je crois que cette finale de coupe on a
tous envie de gagner
j'espère qu'on y arrivera et millions
venant après vos joueurs qui tous
témoignent d'une belle confiance mais
qui sont quand même déterminé qu'ils
sont décidés à faire attention
comment voyez vous cette finale ben je
vois très bien surtout que nous sommes
dans des lieux qui me rappelle très bons
souvenirs et je pense qu' il ne peut pas
maintenant avoir de mauvais souvenirs de
mes aimé cette jeunesse de l'équipe
lyonnaise
elle peut paraître inquiétante mme amon
avis c'est peut-être principale arme je
pense national je crois pas qu'elle soit
inquiétante parce que j'ai des jeunes
qui sont ambitieux enthousiaste qui aime
bien la rigolade bien sûr ils ont beau
tout à l'heure mais je pense aussi
qu'ils sont sérieux et qui savent que
dimanche ils ont un gros boulot à faire
et je suis certain qu'ils sont pervers
[Musique]